I don't have much time left oh grandma
one thing in this world that you need to
know learn how to give a good isn't it
funny how you can never remember much
about some where are you gonna lose your
mouth virginity to her dying wish people
been doing it for thousands of years
it's in the Bible
do you want to like go inside and watch
TV there's something I should probably
just you know today I addressed you all
in tragedy
Dorothy Winkle left us on Friday good
morning Catholic people good morning I'm
sorry I'm Luke Jamie I don't believe in
love at first type but I do believe and
seeing someone and knowing instantly
they're gonna matter to you I thought
you might want to hang out hugs so let's
start going to church I'll just like
give it a whirl go crazy you know what
become the Pope anyone were to find out
about us
we're in us
something had to happen I wanted it to
happen
this is your grandmother reaching out
from the grave
just because your grandma died it
doesn't give you permission to act out
dessert you borrow this t-shirt this
whole thing was a huge mistake
this week was crazy but I think all the
mistakes that we made turned out to be
very good mistakes for us I had nothing
left to lose I felt grandma it's me it's
egging me on Emily's know why she's
grounded at least now I understand why
you wanted to start going to church
[Music]
[Music]
you